i once shot hoops with steve nash in
battery park city
um he was just down there with his
family and i was just a dude
um playing pick up hoops with my friends
and i got there early
and this guy walks by in a hoodie with
his uh kids in like these twin stroller
and i look up and i was like i think my
exact thought was like that
dude in a hoodie is [ __ ] steve nash
what i said to myself and then so this
is an absolutely true story
was this while he was still playing in
the nba or yeah he was literally the
nba's reigning mvp at this point
it was like it was like the mvp of the
league
yeah like no joke so like so so i'm
playing pickup with um
friends in battery park city and i get
there before my friends um
so i'm just there shooting the
basketball alone
and then steve nash reigning nba mvp
comes up to me and says can i shoot
around with you
like like there's a kind of thing that
if you said this was in like a
commercial or whatever you'd be like
this is total nonsense like this is not
the way the world works
eventually i ended up just like
rebounding for him because i felt like a
total [ __ ] being like
now i'm going to shoot and you rebound
for me steve i was like
steve nash rebounding for you i can't
imagine that at all
i would be just clanking everything
[Music]
all right welcome back to yang
speaks this is your co-host zach grauman
it's good to be with you guys it's a new
day in the united states
we have a new president officially joe
biden was sworn in we're recording this
on thursday the 21st so we recorded this
right after
the inauguration and for those of you
who are not trump fans that doesn't mean
you're democrat republican he's
you know you have your own situation but
if you weren't a trump fan today
feels like a sigh of relief in many ways
and it was nice on a personal level i
think
to see some good old-fashioned boring
politics
for those of you who haven't been tuning
in andrew is basically going to be doing
interviews
um in his schedule given his general
political activities and you'll be stuck
with me
for the introductions and i hope to keep
them interesting i hope to keep them
giving you the yang perspective on what
is going
on in the world now before i dive into
it i hope you guys like this new merch
i'm wearing
it is not officially launched yet but if
you like it give me an app on twitter at
zac underscore ground and let me know
what you guys think um
as we start to build out a merch uh
platform for you all to buy over the
next
weeks and months here's what i'd like to
do on these episodes um because if
andrew's gonna be doing conversations
you're not gonna always get yanked's
perspective on the news of the week
and the issues that are hitting home and
some of the more creative stuff or more
timing
timely stuff that we do so what i wanted
to do today is uh is three things i
wanted to give you what i what i think
are the news
updates of the week and what's going on
in the world and then two give you
the yang perspective whether it's andrew
or myself or kind of what the yang gang
zeitgeist is
um that fact based not left or right
forward humanity first perspective for
you and then introduce our speaker today
so i think you guys are gonna enjoy this
let's start with the news
of the week folks news of the week is
the big one a couple things number one
obviously most importantly the buffalo
bills are in the afc championship and if
you're listening this they may have
already clinched
a super bowl appearance i don't know i'm
either crying or doing cartwheels
it's one of the two it's fine we're not
gonna talk about anymore but the buffalo
bills
come on now big news uh second fun piece
of news is bernie sanders is a hilarious
meme at the moment uh bernie's for those
who have not seen it bernie sanders was
at the inauguration and bundled up like
grandpa is at his kid's soccer game
like looking a little over it he's been
photoshopped into every sitting photo
you can imagine
from game of thrones to like a park
bench to civil war photos and it's
pretty hilarious so kudos you bernie
that's internet gold i hope you guys
appreciate this meme
um but more importantly let's talk about
joe biden and what's going on so joe
biden in the first 24 hours has already
signed executive orders
to issue a national mask mandate
on federal property and interstate
travel so if you
are on a flight if you are in a federal
building you have to wear a mask
now for those of you or a yang gang here
listening to the yank speaks for a
libertarian
i understand you're like government
freedoms that kind of thing but guys the
government requires you to wear pants
it's protection of yourself and others
so the mass mandate guys in a global
pandemic
not a big deal not infringement upon
rights if it wasn't a pandemic it'd be a
big deal but guys
come on we we're african ass please for
for everybody the other thing he's
promised
to extend nationwide restrictions
restrictions on home evictions and
foreclosures so
um those were set to lift he's kept them
for those of uh for a lot of people who
are struggling to stay in their home in
in kobe they're struggling economically
people not being able to be kicked out
of their home
which is a smart move to prevent more
homelessness and i think there's
ways you can compensate landlords and
things like that to prevent
everybody from losing money but it is
important to to think of the human side
of covid and then continue to pause
federal student loan payments which i'm
in
big time in favor of couple things he's
done to overturn what trump's done
he has rejoined the paris accords
frankly looking at the paris accords
it's kind of fluff um but it is a good
symbol that climate change is important
so
i don't think that hurts or harms many
things but i hope that we prioritize
climate change because i like this
planet i hope you guys do too
um he's ended the so-called muslim ban
on travel that trump started in 2017
restricted travel and immigration from a
number
of countries to the u.s those countries
included syria iran iraq sudan
libya somalia and yemen um and he's
included a couple others in 2020
that ban is lifted we do have normal
travel restrictions around covid
but he's lifted that back it was a
pledge he promised to do and he has done
it
and he's expected if he hasn't signed it
yet he has signed an order to rescind
the permit for construction of the
keystone pipeline between us and canada
uh very controversial policy
particularly for environmental and
climate change activists
and i don't think canada is thrilled
about that but um generally speaking the
international response to joe's
presidency has been strong for what it's
worth
his also plans that he did promise on
the campaign he hasn't done yet but it
looks like he will do shortly
is to rejoin the world health
organization propose an immigration
reform um for the 11 million
undocumented immigrants
um and give them a roadmap to
citizenship he's planned to do a lot on
climate change to achieve 100 clean
energy
net zero emissions by 2050 transgender
rights and the equality act
um and
a number of things um in the coveted
recovery space which he's promised so
those will be coming down the pipe for
you
to kind of keep an eye out for if you
will
so that's what's happening i'll give you
this and the yang reaction is this is
where we're thinking guys
um we have a great relationship with joe
and kamala i got to know columbus team
in particular
during the presidential run a number of
the debates their staff was always
um very great to work with um and fun
joe's team we got to know our aft
after we got to know more after we
became a surrogate for
joe after we dropped out um
i will say this the relief packages
that are coming down the pike and being
proposed better include cash relief
they better include cash for americans
and if that doesn't happen
andrew will say what needs to be said
when the time is right
let's put it that way he's like the
worst politician ever which i love
um he's human um and so when he sees
something wrong he speaks it he speaks
up about it when he sees a big idea he
speaks up about it not worrying about
the polling the political risks you see
it all the time you see you just follow
him on twitter you see that and but
right now it's important to support joe
and kamala they have a
massive burden on their shoulders the
weight of the world on their shoulders
there's no global recovery recovery
without america we need to lead here we
need them to lead and so
um we will follow their lead and speak
up if we need to
last thing i'll leave with is is an
introduction to our speaker so we have
kevin o'connor on as an mba
analyst and expert um normally with the
ringer
for those who don't like the nba i think
it's still worth or listen um because
they don't talk about sports they talk
about leadership management big
decisions
i love when andrew is talking about
stuff that's not always politically
related because you can't see how his
brain works
in a human setting and you can kind of
get a sense of how he would govern and
what his priorities would be and
how he acts as a regular guy so i hope
you all enjoy it's one of the more fun
ones
i enjoyed it um kevin's a fascinating
guy so tune in now folks
kevin o'connor joining gang speaks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now it is my distinct pleasure to
welcome to yang speaks i should be on
his podcast that would actually be
cooler
one of my favorite nba journalists
someone who i've learned a ton from
about my favorite teams and my not so
favorite teams kevin o'connor
welcome kevin andrew thank you so much
for having me on how you doing this
weekend
i am doing great i'm doing better than
this country
oh boy yeah it's a rough time
in the the good old u.s of a yeah um
but you know we're here to talk about uh
something that hopefully gives us all
uh a bit of relief um which which is
your day job
and kevin i gotta say it's incredible
uh because if you imagine all the
legions of young sports fans out there
so many of them dream about doing a job
like yours and i'm sure you've told the
story in other environments but how the
heck
do you get a job writing about
a sport that most of us essentially
follow for free
[Laughter]
i mean it's something like i always
wanted to work in sports somehow when i
was a teenager i'm 30 now
and you know i was like maybe it'd be
cool to be a sports agent i wonder how
you get on tv but i never really
knew how to do it and then when i was 23
my dad recommended i just sign up for an
internship
at comcast sports at new england now in
bc sports they have those all around the
country and
i applied for that i remember the
interview was like all questions about
the red sox starting lineup
and their pitching rotation i'm like i
can do this this is easy
and then it just sort of snowballed from
there over three years to get hired at
the ringer and the last four years here
with
the ringer and bill simmons and it's
been you know beyond a dream come true
because it's something i always imagined
and dreamed of doing
but didn't know how to do it um so i
feel very very fortunate to do what i do
it's a lot of fun to
you know make connections with people
doing it so did you
uh write about sports during like high
school and college
um you know i did some like writing
contests on local newspapers and like in
my fantasy sports leagues that i used to
play and i used to do like
fake articles so like i've always liked
writing and always like storytelling
and i look back at that time and it's
like i was getting reps
writing stories about my fake fantasy
teams
rather than right you know like writing
on forums and stuff about the celtics i
grew up a boston celtics
fan very spoiled as a boston sports fan
growing up
um and you know what i was always
getting reps
always getting reps and i guess that
helped me once i started as a blogger
um covering the celtics and then
expanding doing a lot of nba draft stuff
so it's always something i like just
never really you know knew how to chase
it
and once i figured that out it sort of
started a role geez man
because your boss bill simmons i feel
like is the godfather
of boston sports bloggers turn big time
[Laughter]
the rest of it so so when when you were
uh like at the new england sports
network uh you know you were producing
articles
like how do you get a quote unquote
discovered by the ringer because i feel
like that's a very big call up
you know so i i don't know for sure but
i've been told by multiple people
at the ringer over the years that they
like the nba draft guide
that i did so starting in 2014 i started
making
nba draft guides with my top 100
scouting reports of all the prospects
that were entering the draft
i did that in 2014 2015 and 2016 all by
myself
and then the ringer noticed that and
they're like oh we could bring this guy
in to do some draft stuff for us
um so it started out and with them
noticing that rather than the stuff that
i was actually doing specifically
covering the nba
and covering the celtics at the time um
but i think the draft was what got their
notice they noticed me with the draft
and then from there they looked at my
other stuff and like hey he's young and
raw you know bring him in and maybe
he'll improve we can work with this guy
we can mold him like a
lump of clay that he is um so uh
so at that point did you move from
boston to california
uh no so i stayed i grew up in brockton
mass my whole life brockton
massachusetts it's like 45 minutes south
of boston home of uh
rocky marciano and marvin hagler grew up
here and uh
i moved to la in january of 2018 so
about a year and a half into working at
the ringer
and then i was there until my dad got
diagnosed with cancer in march of 2019
and then i was home about half the time
until last december 2019 and i've been
in brockton for all but
a couple weeks since then um
for last year and a month uh so i'm in
my childhood bedroom right now recording
this actually get that
green screen behind me in my childhood
bedroom here with my mom now
um in brockton i'll be back in l.a at
some point though i hope post pandemic
well i'm i'm so sorry that your family
has been struggling uh
in in that way i mean i i hope you and
yours are all right uh it's been a
really hard time for
different people in different ways yeah
uh but i know like
for me i'm a bit older than you but my
father
turned 81 and so like at any point in
time you you like
try and appreciate uh family in the time
you have
yeah no doubt about it it's um you know
i wrote an article on the ringer a
couple months after you got diagnosed
just about you know enjoying the moments
and you know cherishing everything you
have with the people that you care about
and the people you love
and you know the pa like i feel like my
life in many ways both in good ways and
bad ways
has felt unreal you know with the good
with like getting higher at the ringer
having this dream job talking to you
you know the bad as well with my dad you
know getting diagnosed with cancer and
passing away after 11 months my mom
having heart
open heart surgery during that like that
none of that feels
real and then the pandemic and now
everybody
is going through some sort of and with
everything else that's happened some
sort of what feels like unreal
it's not something that you imagine
happening in your life and i think that
more than anything else shows how
important it is that you
you really do have to just cherish the
moments that you have
with the people you love because nothing
is guaranteed in life like nobody exempt
from good or bad
things in life and and that's really the
mindset that i
i really try to have in my life every
single day whether things are good
or whether things are bad um that's
really helped me personally you know
with losing my dad
um and i i hope a lot of people you know
going through
all this crap we're going through this
year with the pandemic and the amount of
loss we've had
um i hope people are able to to to find
a little bit of you know joy with the
people they care about
throughout a year like this i hope so
too
brother i really appreciate it uh
everyone appreciates it
and uh what like what a time you and
your family uh been going through
[Music]
let me ask you guys you listen to this
like someone asked me the other day and
it's it was really helpful the question
says
how's your mental health like how you
doing
hanging in there because copied sucks
like there are days a week so i just
don't leave
the apartment i don't leave the house
wherever the heck you are it's brutal
um and i find at times if i don't handle
if i don't approach this
intentionally my mood gets a little
shorter my attention span gets shorter
it's brutal one of our sponsors is
really important to us personally is
it's called better help help better help
it's basically online mental health
resources
um personalized ability to communicate
with someone to help you navigate not
just covet but anything going on in your
brain and i've seen this
like i was just talking to my my youth
pastor um
from home and he's like we're seeing
anxiety and kids like
like my middle schoolers are way more
anxious everybody we're all dealing with
it man so
better help is really cool so you can
start communicating under 48 hours sign
up bang get your
personalized counselor it's not a crisis
line it's it's not even self-help it's
professional professional counseling
done very securely online
so you send a message to your counselor
anytime you get timely and thoughtful
responses and i've done this you just
get somebody to talk to it's all
confidential and convenient professional
affordable if you want to start
living happier getting your mental
health right as a listener you get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com that's
[Music]
betterhelphelp.com
so you probably grew up a boston sports
fan i'm guessing
growing up right outside i'm i'm going
to unpack for you
um my sports allegiance stories
just so we can level set uh and then i
brought you on so you we can talk about
my hometown teams
um the knicks and the nets and i can
learn something from from you and i
actually remember
the first time i think i saw your work
was the nba draft guide and i probably
was probably in the ringer so
uh you know like the rigor is like oh
he's really greeted
well the knicks are always seem to be
drafting high unfortunately
well part of it too i mean like i would
love to hear what you think of the young
players um
you know uh on right now the knicks are
more young players than the nets but i
grew up
uh i was born in upstate new york but i
grew up in a suburb of new york city
and became a hardcore knicks fan during
the ewing knicks era
which it might have been a little bit
before your time so it was like the
early 90s the knicks were always
uh competing very hard but then losing
to the jordan bulls
so this was patrick ewing charles oakley
john starks anthony mason
uh derek harper that crew uh doc rivers
um
losing to jordan then breaking through
in the finals when jordan
uh left to play baseball
that losing to the rockets on the john
stark's horrendous two for 18
shooting performance coming back in 99
with spreewell loved spree well
uh losing again to the spurs uh and then
things get really really rough uh jeff
and gundy leaves and then
uh and then the culture takes a very
very south turn but i was a fan
even through the lean years the isaiah
thomas years the
eddie curry years the like you name it
um
and then linsanity struck and it was
like the greatest time to be a knicks
fan
uh or a sports fan uh that i can still
remember to this day those are good days
good times yeah like so uh i mean at
that point um
uh it seems like you were uh just
getting started but what were your
reflections on insanity
it was just special you know i mean
especially i mean like him going you
know harvard here you know nearby
um it was great to see a young player
come from that school
it was great to see an asian american
shine in the nba
and that was i mean i had friends in
school at the time that were like oh my
goodness
there's an nba player it was asian
american and jeremy lin and they had fun
imagine
being an asian guy who plays basketball
seeing that stuff happen i was like this
is like the greatest thing ever plus
it's your hometown team it was the
greatest time of my my sports life was
great and you know
and like just like never mind like all
that as well like just from a pure
basketball standpoint
he was incredible he had clutch moments
he scored from everywhere around the
court
it was a memorable time for the knicks
and it felt like
that was one of those moments as a
sliver in the last 20 years where it's
like
oh my goodness this team has a chance to
be really special and i
was never at madison square garden for
any of those games i think i've only
went to
two or three knicks games in my life but
the atmosphere atmosphere were there was
great
even when they were losing i can't
imagine what it's like in that building
with you know a packed crowd
when the team's good have you been to
games like that in those did you go to
any length sanding games
uh i did go to an insanity game uh i was
in the garden for larry johnson's
four-point play
uh you're right that the atmosphere in
the garden was good even in bad times
uh like i was first in line for
you're not gonna believe this but msg
had ten dollar
nosebleed tickets for knicks games uh
in the very late 90s uh like
uh when i was a law student between 96
and 99 i would go and get ten dollar
tickets
so the atmosphere was always great but
then at the apex like during playoff
games or during the insanity it was
electric yeah it was the greatest
uh and so at the end of that season when
we let
jeremy lin go because of money uh i
j i just could not handle it anymore i
was like this is the franchise that
paid jerome james 25 million that paid
that paid isaiah thomas like millions
for
you know sexually harassing someone like
but like or like that the
it was just too much uh and so at that
point i threw in the towel and i said
look i i've been
uh eating sleeping and breathing the
knicks
uh since i was a kid um
but dumping jeremy lin for money uh like
was just
like too hard for me to bear in part
because when he was
um taking the world by storm it was like
the the greatest
period of my fandom and then seeing it
disappear
uh in that way uh like i just uh was so
um so hurt really because i thought like
look jeremy lin might not become
like perennial all-star and the rest of
it but i was very confident that it was
going to be our story
uh and the fact that it then became like
the houston rockets
story um so so that was like a real
change in my relationship
uh with the knicks and since then there
haven't been a lot of those stories to
cling on to either it feels like it's
been missed draft pick after miss draft
pick you know miss free agent after miss
free agent
and like now is really the first time
we're at now with the knicks where it's
like okay
things are developed i have not felt
like i've missed anything so
and it's been like better for my mental
health too because uh you know and
and like i have real problems with james
dolan
him banning oakley and banning that fan
like
it's really like the opposite of the
kind of uh team you want to root for
and so during that time i was kind of an
nba
homeless like fan where i was like okay
i'm going to break up with the knicks
now
uh and then a few years later the the
nets brought on jeremy lin
and i was like done like i'm gonna be a
dead fan so i i went to
nets games um i actually saw jeremy
again in person when i was there
and later i became friendly with spencer
dinwiddie
and other folks who are associated with
the nets so
i became a nets fan um and
i don't know how many knicks fans had to
wrestle with any of these feelings over
the last number of years and i did keep
up with the knicks but
i'm just going to rattle off like a few
of the highlight and then we'll get into
what's going on now
um the bright spot of the last number of
years of nick's fandom was clearly
kristaps porzingis
you know he gets drafted over achieves
like the unicorn
um he's putting up numbers and
highlights i mean he has some you know
health issues
um but he's a gamer uh and then
we trade him away for uh cap space
dennis smith jr a couple late
first-round draft picks
and you're like what the hell like if
you were if you were a knicks fan being
like well at least we've got
uh porzingis and then he gets traded for
a bag of chips
uh and the bag of chips then ends up
uh evaporating into thin air because you
can't sign anyone with the cap space
you know what that that trade phil
jackson making that
i i am still willing to bet that he
partially made that trade because of a
lack of trust that porzingis can stay
healthy at all
and so he's cashing in getting some
draft picks right or wrong
that's my belief that that was the logic
part of the logic behind that trade and
with kp
now in dallas i mean he hasn't really
stayed that healthy
like that's the one major concern with
him but ultimately for the mix
for the knicks to make that move at the
time they lost the guy that gave them
hope
that was the one player that you looked
at and felt like there's a potential
of building something around this guy
and you know what hopefully for them
with those draft picks they got back
from dallas they're able to turn that
into something
it's just there's not a lot out there
right now and
kp is going to come back and he's going
to thrive next to luca
yeah so if you're a knicks fan this
would be my big beef
um as someone who who's continued to
follow the team
it's like it's been hard to identify
someone that you can root for that you
think is going to be there
outside anyone you do kind of
emotionally invest in the person
disappears
um so i i said last year i was like i
think this is the darkest time i've ever
seen as a knicks fan and then some
knicks fans actually
like took issue with me um but but i was
like look
at least before you kind of could tell
if you were trying to compete or trying
to build or whatever but like this team
they use their cap space on a bunch of
one-year contracts for a bunch of vet
mercenaries who
are going to need playing time because
you don't sign a one-year deal and then
say like say sure i'm cool like coming
off the bench
and then you had these kids who were
there trying to develop
and it wasn't clear whether they would
actually be played over the vets
like based upon just you know like like
their ability to perform on the court
so i was like this team has like no
direction at all
and is going to have terrible chemistry
and some folks like came to me we're
like oh you'd be too hard on this team
but i was like
this team's gonna be the worst um but
but then now they seem to have turned a
page
and this is i guess what we can get into
now is like the new regime
um as someone who covers the nba
do you uh develop any contacts or
relationships with like uh
like any of the um the folks they bring
in in terms of
coaches and gm's is that like something
that um you get exposed to
yeah definitely and i don't know anybody
you know high up in the knicks
front office um i'm not familiar with
leon rose or
or world wide west um but like when it's
kind of funny like being in it now
since 2013 like i mentioned earlier it's
funny seeing people
who were like lower in organizations at
the time when i first met them now
growing higher in organizations and
maybe someday become gm's or some may
already have become gm's and
it's just cool to see those
relationships develop on their side
because like they're
you know quote-unquote league sources or
front office executives that you know
but they're friends
sometimes at the end of the day in
certain cases and it's great to see
people's profiles rise and with the
knicks from my understanding is with
leon rhodes and world wide west and
the guys there is is that that's a smart
group
um leon rose when they hired him he's
somebody that
i i would trust in that role as general
manager i think the connections that
they have and their mindset about how to
build up a team bodes well
for the nixon with dolan i mean he's not
a good owner he's a very
bad owner some of the decisions that he
made are quite despicable over the years
but one of the things i will say that
could work in new york's favor
is that dolan is pretty hands off when
it comes to allowing the front office to
do the decisions that they want to in
the past that has led to some very bad
decisions
because it's been the wrong people in
place making those choices
but if leon rose and that crew know what
they're doing
at least they're going to have the leash
to do what they want to do to build this
thing out
in some teams that can't be said where
owners are involved in every single
decision that's made from a basketball
standpoint
so for the knicks they definitely are
trending up i'm not so
confident they're going to keep on
winning games this season uh
they still are bottom 10 uh def offense
so far this season their defense has
really carried them some of that is
opponent shooting luck some of it is
definitely better effort
um but they're gonna drop games at some
point over the course of the season like
all young teams do
um but overall the team and the
organization are trending upwards
because of the development and the
flashes
that we're seeing from the young guys
and as well as the hires in the front
office so
you know for knicks fans you know
there's reason for optimism for sure
finally so two things you can say
positively about james dolan as an owner
number one he'll stay out of your way
after he hires you when you're right
like that that actually has gone very
negatively for us
yes because he's like brought out people
who made surprises pros and cons
yeah and number two he's willing to
spend
um like like the payroll hasn't been an
issue unless it's jeremy land
unfortunately but
the payroll has a better issue and uh
and he's willing to pay top dollar for
um management i forget what he paid phil
jackson it was something crazy
something like that was like 60 million
i can't remember it was crazy
but so so those two things count his
favor and if he hires the right people
uh i don't know leon either but i do
know people who know him and by all
accounts he seems like
like a smart guy um and tom thibodeau
uh seems great i know like i associate
tom thibodeau
with like the last real era of nick
greatness um
when he was under jeff van gundy uh and
like i'm a huge jeff van gundy fan i'm
now
friends with stan van gundy and tom
thibodeau seems like he's
from the same general um coaching tree
uh and his teams seem to overachieve i
mean he plays people hard but they
win yeah they win and they try hard
and that's what we've seen with the
knicks so far this season that's the big
been the big differentiator between this
season and last season
is i think more than like any system
changes you know we're seeing
them do some different things especially
with the way they're utilizing julius
randle
on the offensive end but defensively a
lot of it is just straight up effort
you know like okay contributed to that
yeah
and and that a lot of that comes from
thibodeau
and the mentality that he instills in
his teams and the way he empowers guys
and really pushes players
to try their hardest it hasn't always
worked out for him it didn't in
minnesota with cat there
it didn't even you know it worked a bit
with jimmy butler that was a pretty good
team and
i think that's what you you know have to
hold on to it's about building culture
this season like like i said the knicks
are going to end up in the lottery i'd
be surprised if they made the playoffs
in the east i know a lot of next fans
would be
angry at me i think 10 teams make the
playoffs i mean that's a pretty low bar
this time
sure hey i mean you never know you know
julius randle could keep putting up
all-star numbers
he certainly looks better than ever
before but ultimately for the knicks
this year's not about whether they make
the playoffs or not it's about the
progress that they make
and showing that they're a competent
franchise showing that you're a
competent franchise
is what's going to make a player want to
go play for you a star player
whether like we saw this with the
clippers the clippers had a nice you
know gritty
young squad that fought and then kawhi
and paul george wanted to go there
the lakers had brandon ingram and lonzo
ball and all this young talent
and lebron james saw that as a
destination that was worth going to
and with new york if they can put
themselves in that same category that
the two la teams did just recently did
and show that hey you know what we got
rj barrett we got mitchell rob but so we
got a lot of young talent and guess what
if you join us you can win now
that's what the knicks need to become
and get another draft pick
and hit on that um it's about progress
and showing that they can be a team
that's worthy of winning
like they haven't been the last 20 years
[Music]
new sponsor alert i think credit scores
suck
there's no context to them and it's a
brutal way to evaluate whether or not
someone's going to return a loan there
are plenty of people that are going to
be really reliable
who don't particularly have great credit
for a number of thousands of reasons so
i want to talk to you about
upstart it's a fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
and that personal loan can be high
interest debt to credit cards to
personal expenses and a half million
people already use upstart to get this
simple fixed monthly payments and what
they do
is they use more than your credit score
so they have ai and it's like
what 1700 1600 plus data points that
they use on your life
and who you are to see if they can get
you more credit so i love it because
it's flexible it's very human
um it's it's a better way to lend and
better a way to borrow and so they find
smarter rates with trusted partners
because they assess more than just your
credit score so you get this five minute
online rate check
you see your rate up front for loans
from 1 000 to 50
000 that's your range pretty cool you
can receive funds as fast as one
business day so it's really fascinating
find out how to use upstart and how it
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com
yang that's upstart.com yang don't
forget to use this url
let you know we sent you so the loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit
your income and certain other
information that you provide in your
loan application you are loaning money
so be smart check out
upstart.com hope you guys
find it interesting like we did
[Music]
so julius randle has been putting out
monster numbers
uh and there's an interesting thing
about his team i mean you really have to
attribute it to coaching because it's a
lot of the same players
like they're back um knicks fans did not
like julius randle last year
rightfully so last year is my sense of
things i mean
last year's team was not an easy uh team
to root for
um but now nick's fans are looking at
julius randle
thinking like wow this guy is a monster
he's like putting up west brookie in
numbers
uh he's um like
handling the ball making really sweet
plays and passes that you're like wow
julius randle could do that like like
there are times where
you watch some julius randle highlights
uh you think you're
watching like some combination
of like a bigger westbrook or like
even i'm imagining uh so this is the
name then
i know this is not the right comparison
but like i've seen him make some like
magic johnson type
like passing big man uh plays and looks
like
it's not like i mean you know i mean
like i'm exaggerating a little bit but
like
but there have been a lot of plays where
you're like wow i didn't know that
julius randle
uh had that kind of vision uh
so do you think that julius randle's
current level of play
uh well first what is thibodeau done to
like elevate his play if anything
um and two do you think it's sustainable
or not
i think thibodeau's done a couple of
things with randall he's sort of using
the bam out of bio playbook
and with what miami has done with bam
they're letting him bring the ball up
the
floor after defensive rebounds they're
feeding him the ball in the high
post wing area near the three-point line
and allowing him
to make decisions so part of it is the
offensive usage
for randall putting him in positions to
be a playmaker
the other side of it you gotta give
credit to julius randle here
it's pretty clear to me watching his
game that he
recognized the fact that he was just the
turnover machine he was a black hole
at times with the ball in his hands in
recent years throughout his entire
career
for that matter and you're seeing now
anytime he gets some defensive pressure
whether it's a help uh or a full-on
double
when he has the ball in the post he's
looking to pass right away
and he's doing that in transition doing
it in the half court and that's the big
difference between this year's randall
and past versions of randall he's always
had a bit of a playmaking
instinct he's just leaning into it more
and that's encouraging to see
i'm not so sure if he's going to keep up
the shooting numbers he's still turning
the ball over nearly five times a game
like he's probably at his best when he
doesn't have as large of a role
like he does right now but i'll tell you
what randall's a guy i've been critical
of when i did my nba draft guide years
ago in him i did not love randall as a
prospect for a lot of the reasons nick's
fans weren't happy with him
last season defensive effort defensive
focus you know playmaking instincts all
that
but we're seeing the version of randall
that
a lot of people who like this game
thought he could eventually realize and
you know what it's it's encouraging it's
encouraging to see this because
now it's about doing it over a long
period of time and showing that this
isn't just a flash it's not an
aberration
that this is his new reality and if it
is that could be a player that you want
to keep around
it's so wild i'm actually going to be
say like i'm a julius randle optimist
like i feel like if you've like
discovered you can do this kind of thing
i guess
against these teams like i think he ends
up having like a you know really stellar
season maybe not quite at this level but
like i think he's gonna end up
um uh having a great year um
so i'd say right now julius randle like
he's probably the most important
nick on the floor um but the most
important
nick in terms of the future is rj
barrett
uh and you just said something that
really just blew my mind kevin
um which is that you track these players
when they're coming into the league as
draft picks and then you kind of like
see their evolution
um and so like there's almost like no we
we should give you some kind of nickname
so you're evaluating them when they're
prospects then you've seen them in the
league
uh rj barrett's easily the most
important nick because you know like the
hopes of the future
number three draft pick uh star
potential
where are you on rj barrett rj's
progress
year one to year two is encouraging you
know i think we're seeing the 25 plus
point
scoring explo explosions that you wanted
to see more often as a rookie
from him and that's good to see i think
the defense has gotten better
the spacing has gotten better for him to
get to the rim more often
ultimately though his upside is gonna
come down to what level does his jump
shot
actually reached in the most recent next
game that we saw as of recording he
missed a ton of wide open jumpers
completely wide open jumpers and
that's a concern with him what level can
he be as a shooter because you know
as i mean i hate to always just harp on
shooting
but that's the most important skill in
today's nba regardless of position
having a reliable jump shot can be the
difference between being an average
player who doesn't get minutes
and being a quality rotation player
every night can be the difference
between having
being a quality rotation player and
being a starter between being a starter
and an all-star
and with barrett that's what's going to
determine what level he reaches and
with him we've seen glimmers of what
looks like somebody who can be a
franchise player the second best player
on your team
but i think in all likelihood he's
probably that third guy
unless that jumper you know reaches the
level that it needs to but i'll tell you
what though like he's still only 20
years old
and that's something to keep in mind he
is super super young and there's no
doubt that there's raw talent there
jimmy butler you know who tibs helped
develop in the past and chicago
wasn't even in the nba at the time he
was he was not
so barrett needs to be given a lot of
time
but still that jumper and the
development of that skill is
is more critical than anything else
because everything else you can see a
path towards
him being very good overall were you
high on rj barrett uh when
when he was drafted yeah i had him
ranked second i believe behind zion
ahead of drama rant which could end up a
mistake
um but i tend to it would lean towards
the bigger guy
with which rj is rather than ja at the
time i would rank jaw ahead of him now
at this point
um but i still believe in rj and
becoming a really good player
yeah rj has shown a lot of
professionalism like
it does seem like he plays hard he's got
a good work ethic there's no reason to
think that he
uh won't work at his jumper and you know
if his jumper becomes even league
average i think that opens up a lot
uh so so this is going to be fascinating
because the the knicks
roster is replete with lottery picks of
kind of like
um prospects um so
after rj barrett uh it seems like the
most promising
young player is probably mitchell
robinson who is like a second round pick
so
you know he's kind of found uh found
money
if you will um are you a mitchell
robinson fan
at this point for sure i mean his shot
blocking is so
fun how could he not be a mitchell
robinson fan like it's so fun to watch
that guy the defensive end of the floor
and the rim running with his
explosiveness around the rim
he's fun to watch i mean the reason why
he wasn't a first-round
draft pick or a highly regarded guy
out of high school um he did not go to
or play games in college was really just
because of a feel for the game
and his ability to read the floor and
that's what he's he what he has needed
to work on
in his three years in the nba and he's
someone who's got a lot better
uh he's probably not going to be like a
you know a 35 minute per game
guy in his prime years but already he's
averaging nearly
30 you know and he's a starter and
it's gonna be nice to see him develop
under tibs with more time together
because tibs is the right coach for for
getting him as good as he can possibly
get on the defensive inner floor so much
of development
is about situation isn't it it's about
you know whether it's basketball or
no matter what it is you do sometimes
it's about having the right person by
your side to help guide you along and
for robinson he's had he's gotten better
and now he has a coach who is known as a
defensive guy
so this can only be good for him in his
career in his own personal development
so what do you see as a ceiling for
robinson uh starter on a good team do
you think that's a
ceiling i think starter on a good team
you know guy who gets near 30 minutes
per game i i don't see him as like a
star level player you know but i still
see him
as a starter on a good team for sure
i mean if not that you know an energy
big coming off your bench which is still
very important in any league in any team
he he
is fun and he does make uh freakish
plays
essentially every night like you're like
there's one block where you're like wow
that was
he didn't even seem to be near that guy
that like oh yeah he made it happen
blocking three point shots and
everything yeah yeah it's crazy i love
that too like blocking uh blocking
threes
um like uh seems somehow more special
uh so a lot of knicks fans i think
he's probably like the biggest litmus
test for the last number of years is
frank milikina
um and so so that was a weird one where
i think phil jackson
um drafted him and then was like fired
immediately
like like okay that makes sense let the
guy who you're about to fire
make your lottery pick um so so then
frank is out there and uh he seems
very strong defensively and makes the
right play
um but to your earlier point about
shooting being the most important skill
like
his shot seems uncertain but he's also
very young
um and it seems like international frank
milikina
is like a different animal than that
like you know which which spoke earlier
to just really bad coaching but like now
he's got a good coach in tibs
um i you know i'm wondering like
what do you think of frankie smokes i
mean i
i've loved frankie smokes for a long
time i always defended him
on on my show the mismatch that i i host
on tuesdays and fridays with the ringer
my co-host chris martin and i have gone
about
gone back and forth about frank milikina
a lot over the years because
he's somebody who even right now at 22
years old
i'm like if he just gets a jumper he's
got the defensive ability to be a player
knicks fans know
knicks fans know that nilokina is
already one of the better guard
defenders in the nba
because of his size and length and
strength in the chord and intensity and
mindset that he plays with he can play d
at a high level again it's really just
about what level can he reach
as a spot up jump shooter and how much
better does his ball handling get
so he can be a secondary creator for you
like you said he tends to make the right
decisions on the floor
it's just about can he create to be in a
position to make those decisions and
these are basic things dribbling and
shooting
but ultimately for some guys it takes a
long time to develop that
and i i wouldn't be shocked that frank
nilokina is a quality
rotation player on a championship team
when he's like 27 in five years it just
wouldn't shock me
some guys the developmental path is not
linear some guys it takes a lot of
twists and turns and for him
it wouldn't shock me one bit if that's
the path for him i still believe
but it comes down to the jumper
i have this strong feeling that frank
nilokina
is going to be a quality rotation nba
player on a team that is not the new
york knicks
he's barely like under tibs like doesn't
it kind of say something that tibbs
defense first coach isn't giving a lot
of minutes to frank nilla akina that's
probably doesn't bode well for frankie
in uh in new york right now
yeah that's discouraging because i i
like frankie too
um the other recent lottery pick um
which i think there were some like
measurements that were very very
negative on him was kevin knox
uh and kevin knox he's in the rotation
he's he's it seems like he's one of the
first guys off the bench
uh what did you think about kevin knox
as a prospect and now
raw prospects coming out of the draft he
was gonna be his project
yeah and he was the youngest player i
believe in in his draft that year in
2018 and
all that's still true now isn't it still
raw still
still a guy who doesn't look ready to
play and what a shame it is now in year
three how
you look at the knicks and their offense
right now how much of a difference a
quality wing
scorer would make on this team like i
said there are top 10 defense right now
there are bottom 10
bottom 10 offense in the league having
somebody
like a developed kevin knox would make
this team look totally different when it
comes to projecting them forward
but ultimately his shot has not come
together in the way that it needs to
neither has his ball handling nor his
decision making and with him he looks
like another one of those guys where it
wouldn't shock me if in
his second team or his third team he
ends up becoming a quality
nba player we've seen this developmental
path so many times over the years and
that's going to be
the interesting thing for the knicks
because with guys like knox
they're probably more valuable to the
knicks
as a player to trade for somebody who
can come in right away and bring
something
to you because people i talk to around
the league still look at knox as
somebody who could pan out
it's just a matter of the fact that his
value has dropped
significantly since he was a lottery
pick just a couple years ago
and now it's just a straight up project
i want to talk to you guys about public
goods because
sometimes when i shop you buy a brand or
you're looking for a dish
detergent or you're looking for a soap
or looking for whatever it is you're
like is this actually good for the
environment like is this actually like
where does the stuff come from that's
where public goods comes in which is why
we like them this episode
is brought to you by public goods it's a
one-stop shop for sustainable
high quality everyday essentials made
from clean ingredients
at an affordable price so that's
everything from coffee to toilet paper
to shampoo to pet food public goods is
your new everything store and it's
softly designed for the conscious
consumer
it's kind of concerned like where's this
stuff coming from so for rather from
buying from a bunch of single product
brands
you get it all in one i feel good about
buying it because i know it's coming
from a good place
there's a membership model to keep your
costs low because a lot of these like
types of products can be super expensive
so you're getting more savings that way
and you can make your first purchase
without an obligation so
if you don't like it you don't have to
be stuck in like a monthly membership
situation so we worked out an exclusive
deal just for yank speaks podcasts
listeners which i love doing so you
receive 15 bucks 15
off your first publix goods order with
no minimum purchase so basically just 15
free bucks so try something out guys
they're so confident you're gonna love
this stuff and i'm pretty confident that
too public goods we negotiated they're
just gonna give you 15 freaking bucks to
spend on your first purchase so you have
nothing to lose at all just try this
stuff go to publicgoods.com
yang use that code yang at checkout
dot p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s.com forward
slash yang receive 15
15 bucks off your first order just try
something out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm going to touch on uh the main player
we got for kristaps porzingis dennis
smith jr
he was also a lottery pick had a really
good rookie year
uh in dallas or at least goodyear
counting numbers i mean i know there
were problems with him he got a lot of
playing time and put up some numbers
um his highlight reel is a lot of fun i
remember when the
nix first picked him up like you know
someone sent me like his highlights and
i was like ooh
like yeah he's like yeah
yeah he's he's got athleticism he has
gotten
minimal playing time i feel like uh in
new york
um where is the league on dennis smith
not very high on him the the size he's
very small doesn't have a big body
the decision making the shot selection
defense there's a lot of
you know factors working against him in
terms of being
a quality nba player at this point he's
one of those guys who
is going to have to change who he is
you're going to have to see dennis smith
jr over the years take on a more
playmaking
first mindset you know grinding on
defense mindset
rather than being the person that he was
ever since he was a little kid
playing basketball as an explosive you
know score first you know spark plug guy
on your team he's gonna have to change
himself and that's something that may
never happen
it's something that he's gonna have to
do by himself um and
i mean it's just kind of funny like all
these names were listening with the
knicks it's like
so many guys that people loved coming
out of the draft that they were super
high
on it's what they could become and the
knicks have a lot of the kind of really
castaways
it feels like a roster of castaways and
and some of them are going to stick most
of them probably won't
uh dennis smith jr i i don't feel great
about him nor lens noel too another
castaway a guy who is a top lottery pick
who hasn't had the career people
expected you gotta hope
that the other big they just drafted obi
tophan you have to hope that he's going
to be able to stick around and has
it's been an iffy start for him so far
yeah so
they both had um i think some injuries
but
have you gotten any early sense of
either ob top in or a manual quickly and
i gotta say emmanuel quickly has
one of the coolest names i mean like
how can you not succeed with a name like
quickly
quickly for three quickly to the basket
quickly loses his man did you see tom
thibodeau using the quickly pun
recently with one of his gamers yeah
yeah totally
tom david loved that one he was
chuckling at himself but uh
with topping like toph and he's only
played one
regular season game so let's you know
we're not gonna overreact here
with him he's an older prospect uh
played a number of years at dayton
and he's you know got similar qualities
to a player knicks fans probably don't
want to hear a lot about and amari
stodomier because the stadamire er did
not go well
in new york i uh you know i will say as
a knicks fan
uh for part of that time um like i look
back fondly on amari i mean you know
his he had his like knees had problems
and yeah you know like the length of the
contract was a little long but like one
of the most fun teams
um i was just talking to another nba
journalist who said like the two most
fun times covering the knicks were
insanity obviously um and the beginning
of the amari era
yeah pre-melo trade it was like gallow
wilson chandler ray felt in
amari like that was actually like a
really really fun
team anyway so um so i i
i can see the amari obi top in uh
comparison
yeah the the dunking around the rim the
explosiveness the ability to do some
stuff off the dribble with the size that
he has and top and shoot can shoot
threes at at least an average level
with him it's gonna be about defense he
was a poor defender at dayton did not
move laterally well at all
um not a rim protector around the rim
either because even though he's tall at
six eight six nine
he doesn't have the length or or the
ability to really alter or block
shots at a high level in the way that
you need a rim protector to do
but ultimately there's no doubt that
there's talent there from him the thing
that's going to be really interesting
for the knicks over the course of time
is that with toppin one of the other
players that they were really into
around draft time was tyrese halliburton
who went to the sacramento kings
and has really shined there already
making a lot of winning
he's going to succeed in a big way yeah
for sure he'll be in the league forever
and you know what like the knicks made
their choice on top and may very well
turn out to be a good player
but halliburton was one of the other
players that i've been
told that they were strongly considering
and halliburton already off to a great
start i wonder if
we'll look back at some point and say
well maybe the knicks should have
drafted him as we will with a number of
other teams that had an opportunity to
draft halliburton
but i guess i see the mindset they went
with they went with toppin
with their first pick and then they went
with quickly with their next one quickly
being that guy
in that role off the bench you know at
6'3 with a 610 wingspan who brings
energy for you brings shooting
brings secondary shot creation so rather
than drafting two of those guys
they drafted the one of them in quickly
with their later pick and already he's
looking impressive already
and with him the main question people
had about him before the drafts
was with the size you know can he
develop into somebody who runs your
offense more to me i'm not sure that
matters
like he is who he is he can run
secondary pick and roll a little bit for
you handle the ball a bit
but the main thing he does is just bring
energy and intensity
he changes the game in that way and
hopefully he can get better over time
more than he already is
but i liked what the knicks did in the
draft i like what they did in the off
season for that matter i think they
have built what could become a competent
looking team
and already they're winning some games
it's just a matter of continuing this
and continuing to play with effort
quickly is definitely a gem in the late
first round because
realistically a lot of these late first
rounders don't stick
and it seems like quickly he's going to
contribute so that's like a huge win
that's
already a feather in the cap in my mind
of of like the
um leon rose team uh so i'm enjoying
some of the vets that the knicks brought
in
i think most of them aren't short-term
deals um
and i'd say like the biggest confusion
for knicks fans right now is
like again what does this team look like
in a few years who do they invest in
if there was like you know you had polls
for knicks fans
you know a month ago it'd be like julius
randle's gonna be gone by the time like
you know
like like but now julius randle like
might be a keeper
but then if julius randle's a keeper
then you look around and being like
like does obi tophan and rj barrett make
sense on like a julius randle like uh
lead squad and mitchell robinson like
the roster has some
decisions to be made um but i'm really
really enjoying
um austin rivers like like that dude
just seems like a nick
he's like you know just show up in like
a positive way like uh
um and alec burks like out of nowhere
like seems like
you know he's performing like the random
nick cast off veterans
um seem more fun somehow than they did
last year
by a lot nerlins noel i actually kind of
like nerlins too like
you know i mean like nerlins had that
freaking i think it was an offer from
the mavericks that he turned down for
like
i mean i don't want to bring this up for
any you know nerlins
like turned down some contract that's
where that's could be a listener of yank
speaks it's possible
yeah i'm sorry nerlins if you're
listening that was a lot of money but
like
but didn't he turn down some like multi
like tens of millions of dollars turned
out a big contract
and then ended up getting not nearly as
much as that
but this team you know i i really
appreciated austin rivers quote about
and i think you referenced this in your
podcast it's like look i've been on bad
teams and this team has a different
energy and spirit to it
like as a fan that's actually like a
magical thing to hear because
you know you've been through the
doldrums and you're like oh wow like
this isn't the same old mix it's like
actually kind of exciting
um yeah i mean i do feel like the big
question is like what does this team
develop into who ends up becoming like a
real fixture
um because that's been a real
frustration over the last number of
years is like you don't know who's gonna
be around
for sure and like you said there's
decisions to be made
and all these pieces don't fit perfectly
and that's what's going to be so
interesting to see over the course of
time
what does leon rose in this front office
decide to do and which star players
become available
obviously this season has thus far been
defined
by james harden james harden wants to
get out of houston
i'm not convinced harden's gonna end up
getting traded i think that
the rockets have a good group john wall
christian wood even guys coming off the
bench like a j
sean tate who's been an awesome energy
guy for them
my understanding is that and i have this
in my article on the ringer this week
you know it comes out monday after we
record and
um there's a lot of people around the
league who sense optimism increasing
in houston that they'll be able to keep
pardon around he'll be content staying
there
and if that's the case who's the other
star player that can get traded that a
team like the knicks could theoretically
throw their name
into to try to get into and i i look at
bradley beal from washington
the wizards stink they're two and eight
as of recording they have a bottom
defense uh their offense is horrible
when beal's not on the court russell
westbrook looks like a total shell
of his former self the role players have
not been good to me
the wizards look like the team that's
kind of on a path towards blowing it up
and with beale he makes sense
for a team like the knicks to cash in on
some of those draft picks that they got
for kristaps porzingis
and their own picks and maybe see some
young players as well
because beal's only 27 years old he
still fits the timeline of an rj barrett
and the other young guys on the knicks
and he's young enough and well-liked
enough around the league that maybe
somebody else would want to join
along and play with him like if you if
leon rose gave you a call
later today and said hey what do you
think about going for bradley beal
is that something that you would be in
favor of for the knicks
i mean of course like right right
right right now the knicks are still
looking for building blocks
you know like to me bradley beal like
the odds of the knicks getting bradley
beal based upon what could be traded for
him seem
pretty low to me like because i feel
like if washington made bradley beal
available
like every contender would be like the
freaking nuggets could put up like a
much superior offer
[Laughter]
i mean i i wouldn't favor i wouldn't
favor the knicks in like the beale
sweepstakes but
i i think like they're the type of team
that it makes sense
like i said this year but the knicks is
all about appearing to be
a team that's competent i feel like it
makes sense for them to throw themselves
into that
to show that they can be in there in the
race for those star players
and that's something that can set a tone
and draw attention to the team that hey
these knicks are different because they
are different and so they need to show
themselves to be different so i think
about it from a strategic point of view
for the front office
and ownership too they they need to make
players
and other teams around the league and
agents feel like
they are they are ready to bring on
a proven talent because that's
ultimately going to be the goal here
it's not just developing young players
for the next eight years
it's going to be about finding the right
star through a trade or free agency
they need to be positioned for that and
they're on their way and beal might be
the next guy they might not get him
but it's about being ready for whenever
those opportunities become available
wow spoken like you're whispering into
leon rose's ear
that was that was a that was a
tremendous
summary uh well i gotta say this next
team is a lot more rootable than they've
been in years
and any fan is excited just to be able
to watch a team that you can
enjoy um because the team has been been
tough um
yeah so i now have a big ask for you and
i don't know if this is something you
can do
but do you have the power to switch your
madison square garden background into a
barclays background yes you
[Applause]
look at this everyone you should admire
kevin's
diligence i mean jeez
so now we're going to talk about the
brooklyn nets
my team uh like you know of um
i actually was one of their guests uh
for
um during uh the bubble play where like
i i showed up on like their their video
walls that's right
like you know i i went to an in-person
game right before they shut down
and the people in brooklyn were very
nice to me thank you brooklyn that was a
blast
uh so this season started with
so much optimism the optimism's still
there i mean the brooklyn
nets like uh you know could represent
the east like you know they they could
contend all year
but this team was stacked starting the
year like
you start out and you're just looking at
this rotation being like wow they go 10
deep uh they're they're gonna score
i mean i think there was one game they
won like 144 to 140 like the
the team could just uh score on anybody
uh they were a veteran like we just got
through the nixon like all of like the
you know like like uh lottery picks and
whatnot i mean
the brooklyn nets are a totally
different animal where it's just like
veteran
uh contenders um
and then dinwiddie went down and this is
really like the
the to me and you you look at it and you
say well this team still has plenty of
talent even without dinwiddie
um but then after dinwiddie went down
like they've had a real rough patch
um they had you know kevin durant had to
uh sequester because of some kind of
covid contact which shouldn't be a
long-term thing
um kyrie irving missed a couple games uh
for personal reasons that you know like
no one really
uh knows much about but we're just like
i don't even see like just
yeah just like shrugging and saying uh
um
steve nash um steve nash like first let
me say i root for steve nash because he
seems like a great guy
and i i once shot hoops with steve nash
in battery park city
um he was just down there with his
family and i was just a dude
um playing pickup hoops with my friends
and i got there early
and this guy walks by in a hoodie with
his uh kids in like this twin stroller
and i look up and i was like i think my
exact thought was like
that dude in a hoodie is [ __ ] steve
nash
what i said to myself and then so this
is an absolutely true story
was this while he was still playing in
the nba or yeah he was literally the
nba's reigning mvp at this point
it was like it was like the mvp of the
league what uh
yeah like no joke so like so so i'm
playing pickup with um
friends at battery park city and i get
there before my friends
um so i'm just there shooting the
basketball alone
and then steve nash reigning nba mvp
comes up to me and says can i shoot
around with you
like like this is the kind of thing that
if you said this was in like a
commercial or whatever you'd be like
this is total nonsense like this is not
the way the world works
um but this totally happened yeah like i
think i have like
i have friends who that showed up and
saw me shooting around with a random
and then they were like uh huh and then
they recognized more like
like wtf uh and and i i will say also
that steve nash
shooting around randomly on a basketball
court in um
in in new york city um he doesn't shoot
around like a normal person
now what do i mean by that like he
wasn't shooting
like jump shots from various places he
was just shooting
really weird like off balanced
one-footed leaners
where he would like come in and he'd be
like leaning back where he was like
sort of almost like you know almost like
parallel to the crowd and like
it was like he was practicing getting
his shots off with like seven footers
flailing around all
uh getting reps on those weird shots
against
you know common men for under six yeah
yeah i was just standing there being
like oh be my guest
eventually i ended up just like
rebounding for him because i felt like a
total [ __ ] being like
now i'm going to shoot and you rebound
for me steve i was like
steve
i immediately became nervous and started
bricking everything but
he was like a nice enough guy where he
was uh rebounding for me and i was like
this is like against the laws of
like nature that steve nash is
rebounding for my
shitty jump shots right now upon you
andrea
[Music]
today's program of yang speaks is
brought to you by athletic greens with
all the things going on in your world
it's kind of difficult to maintain
natural or effective nutritional habits
and give
your body what is actually needed to
thrive and execute i'm moving into my
apartment i've been here but it's like
this ongoing moving process i'm kind of
busy and
one of the first things i packed was
athletic greens because i love this
stuff i put it in i just every day just
throw it in some water and pound it
and it's this daily all-in-one superfood
powder one scoop of this stuff's got 75
vitamins minerals and whole food
sourced ingredients including a
multivitamin a multi-mineral probiotic
green support a green superfood blend
it's like those green smoothies you got
with like way more vitamins and really
really healthy
and it fits all the diets of those who
are like i'm keto i'm paleo i'm vegan
i'm dairy free i'm gluten free whatever
fits at all
check the box no big deal so right now
athletic greens is doubling down and
supporting your immune system during the
winter months they're offering
our audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase so visit
athleticgreens.comyang
join health experts athletes and health
conscious go-getters
around the world and join us as
someone who's making a daily commitment
to better health every day so that's
[Music]
athleticgreens.com
we've got kevin o'connor back to talk
about the nets post-hardened trade
so we were talking about the knicks and
the nets and then this colossal trade
came down the pike
james harden is a brooklyn net
kyrie is back from his walkabout
that's real ups and downs on the court
hardin triple doubling doing his thing
they dropped two games to the cavs kevin
first let's talk about this trade
brooklyn nets i mean they're going all
in here for sure four first-round draft
picks and
four first-round pick swaps for james
harden like what was your initial
thoughts
like from a fan perspective when that
deal went down
so i i had two thoughts that were in
opposition to each other
um the first is wow you just given your
entire draft future
like i don't even think i've seen like
that number of picks
and swaps uh very very extreme
and you gave up two of my favorite
players from this
uh this roster jared allen and charis
levert
uh and they were they seemed like good
spirited guys young guys with upside
they both were kind of
developed by the team um so all of
that's heading
one direction but then on the other
direction you have an mvp
who wants to come play with your mvp and
uh
that's about it didn't jared allen
himself say it would you do the trade
yeah
i believe taurean prince also was asked
the same question and he said yeah i
would do the trade
so even the guys themselves in the trade
would do it and understandably so i mean
it's bittersweet
think about those guys that were part of
you know and allen and levert as part of
those
fun gritty nets teams with kenny
atkinson head coach together
a couple years back but i mean this is a
trade you do 100 out of 100 times
even despite this you know kind of a up
and down start we've seen from them
uh i felt the same way it's like you
know you know it just boils down
um um to who has the best player on the
court
if you have like the two best players on
the court or maybe three
uh if you include kyrie um so then kyrie
comes back and i gotta say
um you get these really positive young
thunder vibes from kevin durant james
harden then jeff green who a lot of
people forget about but he was like a
very high draft pick who played on those
thunder teams
uh and it seemed like there was some
really good chemistry and camaraderie
and they came out and like harden had
this epic debut and they were like doing
their thing and then you do have to say
that kyrie comes back
and then you're looking at it you're
like um so first one of the things that
occurred to me was that if i was kevin
durant and i came to play with kyrie
irving in part because they signed
together and then kyrie
goes missing for a significant number of
games i mean i
i feel like he missed uh
uh like over five games i think um
like i i had to say that like i feel
like i might be bent out of shape like
if i sign with a team
and uh and then like my you know my my
co-signer
um uh wasn't there and then james harden
shows up and like you you know you go
way back with him that team looked
really really strong
and then kyrie coming back kyrie's super
talented
um but it it did seem like uh like there
was
another adjustment uh that has to be
made for sure
and i think it's gonna take time for the
these guys all to build chemistry even
before
the hardened trade it takes time i mean
they started nine and eight to twenty
ten eleven miami heat started
nine and eight and sometimes you gotta
lose or go through you know some bumps
before you become the team that you
you have the potential to be in with
this nets team
with kyrie taking that time off for
personal reasons he stated that he you
know didn't really want to get into i'm
sure that is tough
you know when that whole team is bought
in and sacrificing in their own
respective ways
um but ultimately katie and kyrie the
fact those guys
chose to play together you know says a
lot about their relationship and their
ability to
to get through any difficult times and i
think the fact that harden wanted to go
there
and his relationship with kd kd is gonna
serve as kind of i think that like
connective glue
on the team he's not necessarily like a
traditional you know
throwback leader he's not like a guy who
yells at people like michael jordan he's
not the lebron type of leader but
for this team a star power team i think
kd can keep these
guys together through a time like this
and losing two games versus cleveland
this kind of like this feels like a
wake-up call
in some ways because you got the cavs
that like this team just fights so
hard every guy on that roster is trying
everything they can to win games and
and steve nash said after i think
friday's game he's like you know we
we're not a defensive team
we have to you know overcome that
through effort and hard work and
communication and
you know maybe for the nets it could be
a good thing for them to drop some of
these games here
because it's going to show the amount of
effort they got to put into the
defensive end they can't just outscore
everybody even though they're gonna put
up a lot of points and that's what
they're gonna really
you know win or lose with his scoring
but their defense does need to be better
and that's my concern with them for sure
so so you say 100 times out of 100 you
make this trade
and i agree um you know they're in it to
win it
now it's clear like it's it's title
contention or bust
um which i appreciate because i i think
that any time a team goes for it in this
way you kind of have to give them credit
uh but you know i i think um
maximizing your uh chances of winning a
title when you're close to it
is the right thing to do and a lot of
teams um
maybe don't take that level of uh
commitment or investment so so you do it
fantastic um you do have some concerns i
agree and
like the cavs game sort of spoke to it
where
you look at the roster and steve nash
said there's not a defensive roster
um so even though you make the trade
a hundred times out of 100 times kevin
and you were very optimistic about the
nets pre-trade you were like look these
guys
could could uh win the east and make it
to the finals and play
probably the lakers look at this stuff
um uh you feel the same way
uh now having gotten a little bit more
like
exposure to them on the court definitely
and you know i think that bucks game the
game they won
granted you know no kyrie i feel like
that game showed the upside here
because this team like you know their
offense has the potential to be like an
all-time
offense like when have we ever seen
three creative genius scorers
you know with their level of talent be
put together on the same roster like
they can play off ball they've played
with other stars in their past
katie obviously you mentioned playing
with hard and prior you know kyrie
playing with
lebron and katie going to golden state
all the stars you know hard and play
within houston
these guys can can make things work and
you guys like joe harris
who is just going to get countless open
shots and he doesn't need to be open to
drain threes this offense is going to be
ridiculous
and with their defense you know when it
comes to wanting to do this trade 100
times out of 100 you raise your ceiling
and you probably
you know make your defense worse but
it's not like kyrie in some of those
finals runs with the cavs didn't show
that when he's
really given a hundred percent that he
can be a really good defensive player at
the guard spot for you it's not like kd
at his peak you know is not one of the
greatest defenders we haven't seen when
he was playing the five for the warriors
he can really
elevate his play and harden once a guy
who people rip for playing poor defense
has become a really solid defender he's
especially like
good on switches against some bigger
guys so the nets
like to me i look at that team and it's
like they need help around the edges
with some of their other winged players
with depth you know finding another big
they just signed
pell who should help a little bit you
know behind deandre jordan but finding
one more
guy to me can help raise the floor
of the team like it's a defensive unit
and you know their ceiling is not just
you know one finals it's multiple and
obviously it's hard to do that and need
a lot of luck along the way too but
having these guys together like could
just lead to some obscene offense with
still pretty good defense with the right
guys around them
are there any available role players
because i know there's some free agents
floating around too
like it like that you think the nets out
there are looking at or should look at
you know i had a conversation with an
exec this week about
that and because we were talking about
the net so i was like who do you think
they would look for who are the guys out
there
and what they said to me was this
because of the league's new rules
with the playing tournament which means
so normally in the nba playoffs
eight teams in each conference 16 total
make the postseason
this year there will be the seven eight
nine and 10 seed
that get to play multiple games for the
seven and eight spot
and the fact that you have more teams
that have a chance to get that 10 spot
that means more teams have reason to win
less reason to let go of players players
have more reason to be bought in and so
on and so forth
which could mean that there's not going
to be a lot of players available for a
team like the nets
to go out there and get like we saw the
lakers get with markeith morris last
year
like we've seen with other you know
teams with championship popes
getting the pass because you know people
around the people are on the league say
the nets are hoping
that andre drummond the cavs center gets
bought out oh my god that's what people
say they're hoping for but that's
unlikely like it's just
it's so unlikely because cleveland's in
it you know they're in it
partially because they're pretty good
but also because they have more playoff
spots to get in
you know so we might not see a lot of
options out there
which is you know i'm not really
answering your question but like
i don't know if there will be many
options this could be a really limited
buyout period and like
they don't have any picks so there's not
much they can trade to actually
get somebody in return maybe a j.j
redick somebody like that from the
pelicans
that's one name i'm serious like jj
is one name i'll throw out there jj can
stroke some threes for you that would be
a great
put jj i mean that would be incredible
but like i feel like jj is way out of
their reach
i i was like thinking of folks that you
know might actually be available
pelicans are bad right now they're bad
really struggling
but they need more more jj's not fewer
jj's i mean
it's like shooting you're right though i
will say this jj a free agent this
coming off season
maybe the pelicans would think let's get
something you know in return jj is from
really not from brooklyn but lives in
brooklyn with his family would make
sense you know
to why you're planting some seeds well
so i mean when i think about the nets
too though it's like i feel like
at least this is like the thinking you
have so you've got
uh the three stars joe harris deandre
jordan
um and like what you think is you need
some gritty role players who'll just go
out there
and throw their bodies around and pass
the ball to one of the three stars
get out of the way yeah like you know
you also got jeff green who you know i
think is going to be like hugely
important on this team actually
um and and so then i like i look up and
i'm just like who the heck could they
get that kind of fits that gritty
role-playing mold he'll just like do his
thing and like you know
like like not um like i mean and this is
just me throwing something out there
this probably doesn't fit but like a pj
tucker title just going like that's a
good one
pj tucker is a great great example of
what they should be going for because
then like you can play him
with jeff green and play that sport and
kevin durant have
switchability and still have really good
defense out on the court
that that makes perfect sense and you
know i reported on the ringer a couple
weeks back that
you know the demand for pj tucker sounds
like three second round draft picks
which doesn't sound like a lot but you
know there are a lot of people around
the league who think it is because he's
35 years old because he's gonna be a
free agent this offseason
and because you know you know outside of
the offense without hardin let's see
what he looks like
granted if he were going to brooklyn he
would be with hardin again and be with
other stars and playing off of them so
that guy that makes perfect sense for
the nets i like that idea i think him or
redick or both
how about that i'm just thinking about
like also like the street freight agents
who are like out there
still like like iman shumpert as an
example like just throw shumpert out
there and have him like you know jamal
crawford
guys like that bring back jabal crawford
why not
exactly i mean it's true there are there
are some solid vets out there that could
be worth an
addition but uh ultimately like the
norvell pell signing is sort of along
the lines of what you're saying
that it is you know and you know they
may we'll see if he sticks or not he was
pretty good with philly
last year in a real limited role uh when
other guys were out but you know
that's what we're probably looking at in
all likelihood for the nets
in terms of what they can add but maybe
like i said like a reddick
or maybe a pj tucker one of those guys
could pop up
um but we'll see how the market develops
it could be a weird year with trades in
the buyout market
man if they were to get drummond i mean
that would be like freaking epic
you know i mean like that's way beyond
what
what i don't know i don't see it happen
personally but
i mean it's just you know people are
like say the nets are hoping he gets
bought out which
we'll see because his trade market when
he was with detroit was so limited they
had a hard time finding anybody that
would take him
and it's not like even though he's
having a solid season much would change
there
but i do think i do think that there
would be enough interest that one team
would at least take them on
for the rest of the season we wouldn't
see a bio but who knows who knows
crazier things have happened in the nba
that's for sure including
james harden getting paired with kevin
durant and kyrie irving
so i'd say like the big thing a lot of
us are thinking is that this team seems
like a
chemistry um exerciser experiment now
um conventional wisdom is that if you
have three stars one of them needs to
sacrifice a bit
um and and it feels like kyrie is the
natural candidate to sacrifice somehow
maybe because of um harden and duran's
pre-existing relationship or like his
relative
um you know uh like size or
or something like for whatever reason it
just feels like that they're mvps
and then it also feels like um like this
like the the chemistry elements gonna be
key and that steve nash
is like the obviously the the um
key figure in trying to manage that
chemistry like am i the only person who
feels like
these two things no i mean
it's definitely a big experiment here
and you know everything i said earlier
about these guys
they could sacrifice and they can't fit
because they have in the past
it doesn't mean it would work you know
circumstances change relationships
change and
and maybe the mix just doesn't work you
know maybe they lose and these guys
clash who knows what
the future brings but you know it's
still at the end of the day it's 100
everything you're saying that putting
these level of stars together who
you know are often isolationists you
know you've given the ball they run a
pick and roll
the defense switches and then they are
on an island it's one-on-one it's like
at the park
and that that can be hard sometimes it
can feel like your turn
my turn and in terms of you know now
it's katie's turn now it's kyrie's turn
now it's harden's turn
and sometimes that can leave this lead
to stagnant offense but ultimately
i feel like james harden when he was in
houston
the last you know four or five years he
became that you know iso player that guy
who's
you know dominating the ball but when he
was in okc
he could run off screens and he could
run off of handoffs and not have the
ball in his hands
and still be a threat and katie himself
went to golden state
improved as a passer became a guy who
played even more off ball than he did in
okc
i feel like those guys have shown a
willingness to do that
when it comes to competing for
championships and that they can do it
again here and ultimately
with brooklyn and steve nash especially
it's going to be on him as the head
coach and that whole coaching staff
to put these players in positions to
succeed and then for the players to play
with the effort necessarily necessary on
defense
to complement what will be a high
scoring offense like this offense is
going to
get up put up points like it's
up to the stars to bring that defensive
mindset to me more so than the offensive
sacrifice like they get to be the
leaders of the defense and
we'll see i mean it's a long season but
i think they can
interesting um it's so it's like a
defensive sacrifice more than an
offensive sacrifice that you think is
being called for i think steve nash
might agree with you
i mean it's it's like the type of thing
where let's say you're not getting you
know
x amount of possessions per game 30
possessions instead you're getting 20.
you get to put that energy you would put
into those extra 10 possessions
into defense you know it that's what
needs to happen
and kyrie i'll say this like before his
hiatus away from the court
when he opened the season the first
couple games he was really busting his
butt on defense
he was setting a tone for the team and
it looked like playoff kyrie and
i don't expect that over the full
regular season he's probably gonna coast
at certain points as you should when you
might
be playing into the finals but if he's
able to turn back to that
level in the playoffs like we've seen
him do in the past
i have a hard time seeing anybody
beating the nets in the eastern
conference like the bucks have too many
holes
some of these other teams have so many
holes i feel like
it could be competitive against the
celtics it could be competitive against
the bucks and
you know the sixers but i still feel
like the nets have higher upside
um than any of these teams wow you heard
it here everyone
kevin o'connor is picking the most
fascinating team
go brooklyn go steve nash i mean
i've got a i mean i'm a fan of a lot of
folks associated with this team
i want steve nash to succeed um so
i hope you are right my friend maybe
we'll have you back to talk about uh
what goes on a little bit later
in the season but thank you for shedding
light on
the next the nets the knicks what's
going on with these teams
uh very high level um really excited for
you to be proven right
let's go i i hope so andrew it's
it's gonna be fun to see these two teams
develop it's been fun to watch them so
far
yeah well thank you first for your
insight um anyone who wants to follow
kevin's nba commentary uh it's
thewringer.com on you have a bunch of
stuff going on right
yeah so i host a couple podcasts the
mismatch with chris vernon on tuesdays
fridays and then i host a pod on
wednesday every other wednesday
on the ringer nba show feed called
ringer nba universe where we talk about
a lot of the young guys in the league
well
that's that's a podcast we'll talk a lot
about the knicks for example
um but uh yeah write on the website the
ringer and
do videos and podcasts there it's a lot
of fun it's been a good season so far
despite the challenges with corona and
everything going on
kevin o'connor is where i go to get
smarter about the nba you guys should do
the same
uh really like and if you look at it he
made his bones
uh being a draft guru dissecting
prospects
uh so you know like he's seen these
folks
um develop thank you so much kevin this
is a blast
and thank you andrew and good luck thank
you for doing all you do
thank you man appreciate the heck out of
[Music]
you
you